[A hospital scene is shown with a doctor sitting behind a desk and a man in a suit sitting next to the desk. There is a jar on the desk. There are fabric screens behind them.]
[A close up of the jar is shown. There is a label on the jar that says, "Calomel Ointment."]
[The doctor opens the jar and dips his fingers in the ointment. The doctor smears the ointment on one of his fingers.]
[Pharmaceutical preparations in boxes or bottles are shown.]
[A table is shown with a glass bottle with a stopper and a glass.]
[Liquid is poured from the bottle to the glass.]
[A close up is shown of powder from a small bottle being added to the liquid in the glass.]
[The liquid is shown being pulled up into a syringe.]
[A close up of an arm with a tattoo is shown. The arm is sterilized and the syringe with needle is inserted into the arm. The liquid is pushed slowly from the syringe into the vein.]
[A doctor is shown with a male patient. The doctor is tapping the chest of the man.]
[The doctor listens to the patient's breathing using a stethoscope.]
[The doctor takes the blood pressure of the patient.]
[The doctor is shown giving an eye test to the patient.]
[The doctor lifts the eyelids of the patient and looks in them.]
[There is a room shown with a patient almost completely enclosed in a machine. Only the head of the patient is sticking out. There is a small table next to the machine with a fan on it.]
[A technician wipes the head of the patient and then checks something inside the machine.]
[Close-up of the technician wiping the forehead of the person in the machine and then giving them a drink.]
[The patient is shown still in the machine.]
[The technician checks a printout on the machine.]
[A man is shown in a hospital bed. A nurse and a doctor take a blood sample.]
[A doctor is shown sitting behind a desk and a man is seated with his back to the camera beside the desk.]
[The doctor is talking to the man and writing something down.]
[The man stands up, removes his jacket and sits back down. The doctor ties a tourniquet around the man's arm.]
[The doctor takes a syringe out of a box and prepares the man's arm for taking blood.]
[A doctor is seated at a desk. He rises as a couple comes into the room.]
[The man stands in front of the desk and the woman sits in the chair next to the desk with her back to the camera. The doctor sits back down.]
[The doctor ties a tourniquet on the woman's upper arm and prepares to take blood.]
[The woman is now standing in front of the desk and the man is seated by the desk. The doctor ties the tourniquet onto the man's arm.]
[The woman opens the door and enters the clinic.]
[The woman approaches a desk with another woman seated at it. This woman points off camera and the first woman turns in that direction.]
[The woman approaches a desk with a doctor seated behind it and sits down in a chair next to the desk with her back to the door.]
[The doctor talks to the woman and writes something down.]
[The doctor stands up and ties a tourniquet onto the woman's upper arm.]
[Close-up of a child's mouth. Someone's hands are holding the lips away from the mouth and pointing out problems with the teeth.]
[A girl is shown facing the camera and then a man turns her head to show a deformity of the chin and facial structure.]
[Another girl is shown with severe deformities of the facial structure. Her head is gradually turned so she is facing the camera.]
[A boy is shown facing the camera. He has deformities and does not look normal.]
[A man, woman and baby are shown outside sitting in the grass. The woman is holding the baby. The couple are playing with the child.]
[A woman is shown seated behind a desk. A man enters the room and sits down in a chair next to the desk with his back to the camera.]
[The man and woman are talking.]
[A laboratory is shown with three men working with scientific equipment.]
[A male scientist is shown looking into a microscope and adjusting the focus]
[A female scientist is shown working with scientific equipment. She puts a slide under the microscope and adjusts the focus]
[Close-up of equipment which slices something thinly. These slices are then put into a glass dish half-filled with solution.]
[A male scientist removes something from a covered Petri dish and puts it on a slide.]
[A man is shown walking down the street.]
[The man stops and looks up at the building.]
[The man enters the building as another man walks down the street.]
[The man walks up to a desk in the building which has a nurse seated behind it.]
[The nurse points to a hallway and the man turns and walks down the hallway.]
[Bottles, boxes and advertisements relating to syphilis are shown]
[A man is in a hallway looking at an advertisment on the wall]